éducation à présent jeudi 9 juin une
cinquantaine élèves de terminale c'est
la section européenne du lycée hôtelier
de guyancourt ont reçu leur repasse lors
d'une cérémonie
une manière de conclure leur formation
de trois ans alors leur passe valide
leur stage à l'étranger effectuées en
2015 une expérience professionnelle de 2
mois réalisées au sein l'établissement
reconnu en irlande en écosse où
notamment en estonie dans des hôtels et
des bases de 4 au 5 étoiles la filière
section européenne permet de
sensibiliser les jeunes à la citoyenneté
européenne de renforcer lors anglais et
de devenir plus autonomes on écoute les
réactions des professeurs mais aussi des
élèves
ça clôt l'année scolaire ce n'est pas
diplôme en mai c'est juste une
valorisation de leur expérience
professionnelle c'est un moment fort de
leur scolarité
c'est un moment c'est un moment où on se
retrouve on va fêter quelque chose en
plus de collaboratif d'agréable ça
permet d'avoir la réussite d'avoir
accompli parce qu'on a fait pendant ces
trois ans donc je trie ce que ben
hassine une belle concrétisation
c'est formidable et ça fait trois ans
que je suis ici j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses j'ai fait
en stage à l'étranger donc c'est super
bien passé et j'ai fait but de ce stage
en france qui sont supérieures possible
voilà